thanks jc all right thank you for for
sticking with us yes let's get back to
the brow you've got the highlight
underneath now let's talk about some of
the lid colors for spring what is going
to be big for some of the lid colors
yeah so you got to bring out you think
about orange you think about
um october but i want you to think about
the spring orange right so very like
easter ish very like popping bringing
that color in right on the eyelid so
this color here it has a beautiful sort
of tangerine apricot kind of look that's
one of the go-to colors this season and
you put it right on top of your eyelid
and for the people who don't know how to
do a whole lot like literally this could
be your one color right on top of your
eyelid and kind of do the trick honestly
if i saw that color in the store i'd be
so intimidated but when you put that on
it looks beautiful and because we're
doing so much still on the internet to
be honest you need to almost do your
makeup like you're doing it for tv so
you need a color that kind of pops a
little bit so it'll show up on screen
you just really gave me the confidence
to use a color that i would not normally
use i love that
oh my goodness okay and let's talk about
a trick that you have for those of us
that want to really accentuate our
cheekbones okay so
one of the biggest strand is a
monochromatic look so we're taking the
color from the eyelid and we're going to
bring it right to the cheek okay so i'm
actually using the same color
but i'm going to do it right on her on
her cheekbone here so you want to go
right on the cheekbone on top of the
cheekbone and you want to bring it all
the way back to the hairline
okay one of the biggest trends right now
is sort of to help the face look lifted
if you take and you bring it back to the
hairline just a little bit it's actually
going to make the face look more raised
i don't know about you but i like a
little lift i like a little left i mean
dad literally just pulled her her
cheeks up
and again i just can't get over that
color how i would never buy that but now
i'm like where did you get that i want
to get it actually exactly this color
here is available only beauty um and i
actually do a show on topshop live
talkshop.live where i actually do makeup
tutorials and sell the products okay so
that that's how people can get in touch
with you if they want more information
go to talkshop.live that is beautiful
and our model here looks absolutely
stunning great tips and tricks love it
thank you so much for taking the time
you are so excited i'm going to send it
over to you